good morning and welcome I'm Sachi up
shake I'm a software engineer in the
artificial intelligence and research
group
I'm also blind and on stackoverflow my
highest voted answer is how can you code
if you can't see so I thought ok I'm
gonna show you that today the answer of
course is using visual studio and I also
happen to use a screen reader which runs
in the background and narrates what is
on this happening on the screen so that
okay I'm going to show you how I code a
simple program in visual studio so
that's speaking really fast and in a
robotic voice that's how I code because
I want to be as efficient as possible so
this is the challenge can't you
understand what it says
[Applause]
okay so if you know file new project
know what might get a code this is a
hoist a bit of a dilemma
I felt hello world is a bit a bit boring
so let's do a hello talk talking hello
world so I need to add a reference to
the speech line and let's I'd be using
at the top and just like for anyone else
it's reading me out the intellisense so
don't have to do all that typing so
let's continue with this epic program
and let's press f5 and see if we can
build hello world yay
now I've been using Visual Studio since
I was at high school and got it in the
back of a book so and and it's always
been somewhat accessible but they've
always been these little challenges you
know this little screen here or this
little thing there's less than perfect
so a year ago roughly I got to sit down
with the vs team and I walked them
through some of this and I think they
were you know this don't they basically
have renewed their accessibility efforts
which is so good news for someone like
myself and they've gone through
systematically analyzing these our
interface identifying all the areas
where there needed to be a few
accessibility improvements for example
making sure it works with high contrast
or that you can use it with the keyboard
or that the accessibility API czar
implemented so they went through and
they've done that and we're starting to
see the changes today which is amazing
for me and I'm gonna show you just some
of that maybe the biggest pain point for
me was using the debugger like the
locals window it used to be not
accessible so used to actually have to
copy text out of the deep where the
locals window into notepad so they could
read what the variable value was and
that sucked and then look at the
debugging experience hello world and
let's see if I still work
there's a crate at the end okay get rid
of that yay yeah we're back in action
okay so now let's put a breakpoint here
so we can try it with the command-line
arguments and we say put a breakpoint
there
run it again and here we hit the
breakpoint so let's go into this bird
debugger window which was formerly
inaccessible and it's telling me args
has length 0 so let's just edit that so
now we can even expand this and it's
treating it like a tree view which it
should and it's you know I can go
through all the elements of the array
and if we just continue
cool so this is just it with these
things often it's just the small changes
with matter
for example that locals window one of
the developers just went through and
made sure that it implemented all the
accessibility API but it makes such a
big difference to my productivity and
the way that I code everyday so maybe if
you work on any user interfaces be there
desktop mobile or web then these small
changes in your apps could make a real
big difference to someone who uses your
app slightly differently thank you
[Applause]